Gisele Bundchen living her best life in
Brazil I'm just gonna dance the model
celebrating Carnival in Rio de Janeiro
and documenting all the fun she's having
in her home country
[Applause]
at one point Giselle gets lost in the
samba music and lets her feet do the
talking
foreign
[Music]
outfit looks familiar it's because it's
a total Recreation of The Ensemble she
rocked in 2004 the cropped shirt that
reads Brahma a nod to the Hindu god
white low-rise pants and her washboard
abs still chiseled as ever
but before taking the festival by storm
G got some practice in days prior she
filmed herself getting in the mood for
Carnival with her friend and
choreographer Justin Neato
[Music]
to me Beauty means how the woman carries
herself how she smiles how she stands
how she
how she she's comfortable her skin and
confident and secure of herself because
that I think is beautiful also beautiful
giselle's new era as a single gal she
and her ex-husband Tom Brady finalized
their divorce in October after 13 years
of marriage the good news is things it's
a very amicable situation and since
they're split giselle's been spending a
lot of time in her native Brazil in
December she celebrated the holidays
with their two children Vivian and
Benjamin then shortly after the New Year
the supermodel shared this photo
meditating in a rainforest I'll get to
the point right away
I'm retiring
for good a big point of contention in
their relationship Tom's long-standing
commitment to football retiring in 2022
only to unretire before officially
hanging up his jersey earlier this month
I really thank you guys so much to every
single one of you
for supporting me my family
my friends my teammates and I feel like
I'm so driven to succeed in football and
that's taken me away from
other important priorities which are my
kids my wife and she's really held it
down for our family
forced Giselle still made it a point to
Point typically congratulate Tom writing
quote wishing you only wonderful things
in this new chapter of your life
[Music]